uh martina
so pre-processing in qpf
is extremely important uh
one of the first papers on this was
co-offered by martina
on for qbf and this is actually one of
the most cited papers
in qbf and she also have been doing
a lot of additional uh
work on this topic later on and also
recently co
offered also a chapter in the the new
handbook
which also covers these techniques i'm
very excited to hear about
what martina will say about the
pre-processing for qbf and how
how that impacts solving martina thank
you very much marine
uh in principle you already told the
whole story uh
so pre-processing is in very important
for qbf
solving so nowadays almost all solvers
uh use preprocessors are submitted with
preprocessors to the competition
otherwise
they would not work so well as
as they do nowadays um this
[Music]
relates not only to search-based qbs qbf
solvers which
are based on cdcl solving but also to
expansion based solvers
and the only solvers which do not use
pre-processing
are those solvers which try to
reconstruct the structure of a cnf
formula
and uh which then uh exploit non-cnf
um structure explicitly but all other
solvers nowadays use preprocessors and
here
i have a good old cactus plot uh showing
a picture we see with
most recent uh preprocessors
so this is with with my preprocessor
blogger
and um in in the dark colors we have the
um solvers we have three solvers here um
yeah it's it's not the recent picture
but
for reason so that's the same in the
dark colors we have the
results for the solar swift
pre-processes and in the light colors
without pre-processing
um yeah it's a cactus plot so on the
x-axis we have the number of solved
formulas
and uh on the y-axis we have the runtime
the more to the right we are the better
uh there is this results are and we see
that
um in all cases
uh pre-processing uh considerably
increases the number
of solved formulas and this is a picture
we repeatedly see
and uh there there is blogger
preprocessor from linz there is a
pre-processor from freiburg
and there is also a lot of work on
pre-processing by florian
lonsing which he did when he was at
tiovin
uh he's now at stanford and yeah
there are a lot of um investigations or
some pre-processings and
i i would like to show you uh some of
the most fundamental techniques
uh which we found in most preprocessors
nowadays
so before we jump into pre-processing
let's
reconsider what a qbf is we consider
qbf's in brinix conjunctive normal form
this means we have two parts in the
formula we have the prefix
uh the quantifier prefix and
we have the matrix which is a
propositional formula in cnf we assume
that the formulas
we are considering are closed this means
that
all variables have a quantifier either
an existential quantifier or a universal
quantifier
and yeah
the propositional part is in conjunctive
normal form
so we have a conjunction of clauses a
clause is a disjunction of literals as
usual
and the important thing is that the
ordering of the quantifiers
imposes an order on the variables
um so we do not have the same freedom
as in in sat where we can
pick any variable to process next but we
have to be very careful
about the ordering of the quantifiers
otherwise we
would change the meaning of a formula
important thing is that every formula
can be transformed
into an equivalent uh formula in a
prenux conjunctive normal form or a
satisfiability equivalent formula in
linux conjunctive normal form
we also have a version of satin
transformation of
plastic cling bomb transformation and in
a similar way as
in insat as benjamin already explained
this this transformations
somehow blur information
in the within the problem encoding and
this information can is then harder to
be used during solving and
the pre-processing techniques help to
make this
information explicit again and to
eliminate redundancies
um yeah about the semantics um
the standard semantics is when we have a
qbf
which starts with a universal quantifier
say for all
x then this formula is true if the
formula
which we obtain by replacing x by true
is true and
if we set x to force uh is also
true and dually we define existential
quantification
uh arithmetics of existential
quantification uh so
uh at least uh one of the two formulas
we obtain
by replacing x by truth value has to be
true in order
that the qbf is true
and um yeah here i i have an example
uh for all x exists y and
uh yeah in this case i have x is
equivalent to y
and um
in the case of the universal quantifier
we have to check both values
for the x and in the case of the
existential quantifier we need
at least we need to consider at least
one assignment to the variable
to identify the truth value of the
formula
and in consequence it's not enough
uh as in such to consider one assignment
of the variables but
we have an assignment tree as we have it
here so
for universal quantifiers we have two
branches and for existential quantifiers
we have one branches
in a qbf model and
yeah here i have again a summary of
qbf models and counter models and so
here
we have the model of a true formula and
dually and this is also a bit different
as in sat
so in qbf we have a duality between true
and force formulas
so there is no easy part for for the
checking when when we found
a formula to be true and just check if
the assignment is indeed an assignment
but uh it's our tool in qbf reasoning
and uh for a fourth uh formula the
the counter models have the uh
dual structure here we have two uh
branches
for the existential variables and one
branch for the
universal uh variables in the assignment
tree and
yeah it's important in a model the
assignments in the assignment tree
or in the model make the formula
and in a false formula that the
assignments
in the counter model uh make the formula
forms
and this is one representation of
models and counter models for qbfs but
this is not a very practical
what we are interested in in practical
qbf solving is to get
so-called scrolling and tab function
functions in the case of a true qbf this
column function
is a function which
describes the value of a
of an existential variable based on the
preceding so under under variables to
the left in the prefix
uh which are universally quantified and
the dual we have for
for false formulas there we have
so-called functions which
um give solutions to uh universal
quantified variables yeah and we we need
uh this uh functions in practical qbf
solving because uh they give the
solution to the application problem
for example if we solve a bounded model
checking
problem that is encoded in qbf we want
to have uh an error trace
in case that um there is a bug in the
program that we are checking or if we
are
encoding a synthesis problem we want to
have
the synthesized program or if we we are
using qbfs for for game playing we want
to have a playing strategy and therefore
we are interested also in getting these
functions and it's not enough
for for a qbf solver just to return true
or false
yeah this is a short hiccup on
qbf semantics and now i come already
to a pre-processing technique so i
have selected a couple of uh important
pre-processing techniques but there are
many more
um the first of all there are quantifier
agnostic pre-processing techniques which
work as insat and do not take care
or do not have to take care about
quantifiers
as we will see there are many techniques
which are
similar as the techniques that benjamin
presented but where we have to be
careful about the quantifiers but there
are several
where we do not have this issue
and the simplest one is tautology
elimination
so if we have a tautological clause as
in sat we can simply skip it
then we have subsumption which is also
defined as inset
and also self-subsuming resolution
works for qpf um benjamin already
explained this so i
will not go into this in details again
yeah then uh let's come to the first uh
important um qbf pre-processing
techniques
uh technique which i would like to
introduce and this is universal
reduction
and uh universal reduction is a very
prominent technique in in qbf research
because it's um yeah it's it's the
technique that
makes the difference for between qbf
proof systems and such
proof systems so if you have a subpro
system
and like like resolution
and then you get a qbf
version of it by adding a universal
reduction roughly speaking
and yeah so a universal reduction was
introduced in 1995
by by clanny bunning and others in order
to give
a resolution calculus for qbfs and
the resolution rule that the basic
resolution hole for qbfs is
similar as the existential rule that
or the introduced
there are many variants of it but in
in the first characterization it
principally worked
like like in sat with existential
previous
and in order to to make
the proof system complete for
[Music]
qbfs a second rule was needed and this
was universal reduction
and the idea behind or universal
reduction
works as follows so assume we have a qbf
in prenux conjunctive normal form
and a clause then we take this clause
and um or order the literals
in this clause according to the order um
they their variables occur in the
quantifier prefix
and uh if we have a literal
in the clause in this sorted clause
that has no uh
literal in this clause that occurs whose
variable occurs
to the right of this universal literal
in in in the quantifier prefix and this
literally is existentially quantified
then we can remove uh the universal
literal uh so let's look at an example
uh here we we have a qbf formula with a
prefix
exists x for all a exists y x is c
and uh here we have this clause here
and this clause uh contains not x or
a and um yeah the literals are
already ordered sold it uh we have
first the outermost existential literal
and then we have the universal literal
and since there is no other existential
literal which is to the right of
a in the prefix we can omit a
so yeah i don't know if you see it but a
is now gray so we
we can omit the a and this is universal
reduction
this is a first pre-processing rule
and this is also used
for transferring the concept of
unit literals and unit clauses to qbf
in such a unit clause is a clause of
size 1.
in in qbf
we we have a bit a different
definition of a unit clause we say that
a unit clause contains exactly
exactly one existential literal
and there may be
an arbitrary number of universal
literals but
they have to be to the right of the
existential literal and the prefix
yeah so in principle um we could also
remove them by universal reduction
and then have only a clause of size one
but the standard definition is to have
this
in this this
definition including uh the literals
the universal literals and
the existential literal is called the
unit literal
and uh yeah what's also important if we
have a clause consisting only of
universal uh variables then the formula
is immediately force
because um then we can remove the
the literals by universal reduction
but here is important is that we are
very careful about tautologies so
the qvf rules always have side
conditions about pathologies in order
that nothing to avoid that something
goes wrong with tautologies
uh yeah this but this is a topic on its
own so in our example
uh we have this clause here which is a
unit clause
x is um not x is the unit literal
and if we have
such a unit
clause then we can remove
all clauses in in which this unit
literal
appears and remove the occurrences of
the literal with the opposite polarity
so uh here we can remove the x
from this clause and we can remove
the the other three clauses because they
contain and not
x this is a unit literal elimination in
qbf
and um
[Music]
this is plays also a very important
role in pre-processing uh
in in qbf um what is also very important
and what is also sometimes considered as
part of pcb
is a pure literal elimination so in qvf
we are happy
with any technique that allows us to
[Music]
to avoid the quantifier ordering and
[Music]
have decisions early and uh here an
important rule is
um existential pure literal rule and
later on
we'll see there is also a dual version
of it and
we call an existential literal pure in
the qbf
if only l occurs
but not not l so the literal occurs
only in one polarity
and if we have such a pure literal we
can remove
all clauses
[Music]
that contain this literal and this
existential pure literal can be at any
position
in the quantifier prefix as soon as as
soon as the literal has become pure
we can uh remove it uh here i i have a
formula yeah where i uh forgot to write
down
the quantifier prefix this is let's
assume all our variables are
existentially quantified then so we have
a or not c
c or not d b or d a
and b are pure so we can remove
uh the two clauses now c or d
is the only clause c or not d is the
only clause that is left
and uh we see that
now for example c is also pure and we
can also or
not d is also pure and then we can omit
this clause as well
and conclude that the formula is true
yeah uh and
benjamin talked about blocked literals
and
blocked clauses and we have a similar
thing
in uh qbf as
um already mentioned
we introduced this quite a while ago
so this is the first joint work with
amin beer and florian lonsing
and um this also plays an important
very important role in qbf
pre-processing
and the definition of a block drill
of an existential block literal is very
similar as in sat
with the only restriction that we have
to respect
quantifier ordering in the context of
qbf
so um what we have to take care of
is that so or let's recapitulate what is
a blocked clause
um a blocked clause is a clause
that contains uh a literal
l and um if if i
build all possible uh the solvents or
these literals
over this literal then they are all
pathologies this is the definition in
sat
and in in qbf we we have the restriction
that the literals which
form the tautology are to the left
of of the of the literal
um that gives us the blocking property
so with the blocked literal um and
when we found a blocked clause so a
clause with a block literal
then we are allowed to remove the clause
and um
[Music]
satisfiability is preserved and
as in such it's a very powerful
simplification technique
because it can uncover some structure of
the normal form transformation it can
simulate certain circuit optimization
techniques
and yeah it's it's a general uh
generalization of existential pure
literal
elimination because in in pure literal
elimination
obviously we do not have any resolvence
and therefore
can immediately
omit the clause so the pure literalism
is a blocked literal as well
here i have an example we have the the
formula for all x
exists y and um
the uh not y here for example
is a is a blocked literal because if we
uh
built uh all of a solvents which is only
one we get
x or not x and uh this is a tautology
and therefore
we can conclude uh that um
the first clause is a blocked clause uh
obviously the second closest and also
blocked clause
and therefore we can conclude that this
formula
is true in contrast the the x
here which is on the first position is
not
a blocked literal first of all it's
universal and second even if it was
now let's let's talk about this later so
it's it's not the block
block literal at the moment because it's
uh an exis
it's not an existential literal we will
soon into talk about
uh a variant where we also consider uh
universal variables
yeah and this can be even more
generalized
and this is this was joint work with
amin
and for for qbf we can
also introduce a
variant of the the red rule which is now
very
popular in inside solving and we called
this curette and
yeah i think i don't we'll go into the
technical details but
here again the important thing is that
we have to take care
about the dependencies and red
uses the solvents and this they have
certain properties
and here again it's important that um we
cannot
use the full resolvent as we do it in
sats but
we don't take only a part with
which contains only literals with
variables
to the left of the literal with which
which has the red
which is important for the red property
yeah
and um
yeah and if we um
have a clause which has this
pureed property with an existential
literal then
this can either be used for clause
addition or clause elimination
uh this is a generalization of
existential blocked literals
and um yeah it can be even more
so so curate uses propositional
pcp for checking and it can be even more
generalized to and use qbf pcp and floor
and launching
has a preprocessor which implements this
um which which uses a curette and an
extension of it for for pre-processing
and this is also very powerful uh in
this
in this context now
okay yeah but the the main point i would
like to make here it's very similar as
insat
the rat property only with the
restriction that we have to take care of
quantifier dependencies and may not take
full resolvence but only parts of it
yeah and then the question is what is
about universals
so if we consider this formula where we
have swapped
uh positions of the universal and the
existential variable so we have now
exists y for all x uh then
if we if we
perform resolution over the universal
variable we would get a tautology
and
the question is can we also
use this
and when we
[Music]
simply would omit the clauses then
obviously
a force formula would become true and
uh what we have here now is that we do
not have
so so all the techniques i presented
before so
pure literal elimination block closely
blocked
clauses and um also
curate transfer to universal literals
but there we do not eliminate clauses
but we eliminate
literals and um
so the the definitions are besides some
technical details very similar
but um with um with
um these um techniques on universal
literals
we do not add or remove clauses but we
add
or remove literals and we require that
they have their respective properties so
for example
if a literal a universal literal is pure
in a formula then we can remove it from
all clauses
and uh similar with a universal literal
uh with universal blocked literals or
curate literals
yeah then very important
um in qbf pre-processing is a universal
expansion this goes back to
a in 2004 the qantas over
where he introduced the resolve and
expand
paradigm and he he observed
that when we do expansional universals
that
the cnf structure is
preserved and
expansion is extremely powerful in the
context of qbf solving and nowadays
there are
a lot of solvers that
use expansion in in combination with
with abstraction refinement approach so
we incrementally built
and build up an expansion of a formula
until uh the formula can be decided
um here then subsolver is used for
deciding it
but uh in in qbf we in in previous
processing
inquiry of preprocessing we use
expansion
to eliminate certain variables and
this is a bounded approach of the of the
quantum approach
so if we have a qbf which has
a universal variable a in the innermost
universal quantifier block so afterwards
our existential variable
then the idea is to um eliminate
this universal variable by setting it
wants to true and once to false and
in order to uh
get an equivalent formula we have
we have to be a bit careful about the
variables to the right
so about the existential variables to
the right in in one copy of the formula
we have to
rename them because they
might depend on the variable which we
eliminate
yeah and here we we have some
uh heuristics which uh say
if it's a good idea to to eliminate a
universal variable
so we do not eliminate all but only if
the blow up does not
exceed a certain limit and this
is a very very powerful technique in qbf
pre-processing because
it can shrink the number of qualified
quantifier alternations
yeah here i have an example here is
exists x for all u
exists y and we eliminate the u variable
and uh we replace you once by by force
and once by top and in one copy we
rename
uh existential variables
and to get a simpler formula
uh then existential variable elimination
this is
also very similar as benjamin
discussed it this is also a bounded
variable elimination
we apply davis batman on
innermost existential variable this also
process
preserves uh cnf structure um
here yeah it's really similar as in sat
if we do it on the innermost
existential variables there are also
works which do it on other
variables and variables at other
positions in the prefix
but then there are also some side
constraints that have to be respected
and uh this also uh yeah is um
has to be done very carefully in order
to avoid exponential blow up
but this can also help to eliminate
certain variables and
then give more structural information
back to the solar one
yeah here i have also an example and
we eliminate the y and then there are
two good things on the one hand we if we
build all the solvents we get
two we get
we get tautologies and also that you
is is
innermost quantified and then we can
apply universal detection
yeah and if we now uh have a
preprocessor
uh and give a formula to it then
uh either we obtain a formula that
is now different in a structure and can
then
hopefully easier be solved by a solver
or
uh often it happens that the
preprocessor
mainly because of this resolve and
expand paradigm that is
partially implemented uh source
uh the formula and
um yeah
so uh then there are two challenges we
we worked on over the last year what are
your last years and
one is to validate the correctness of
the results and the other one is to
extract solutions so we want to have
especially for the two formulas uh the
functions so
if if we get a solution for the
pre-processed formula
then this is not a solution to the
original problem
and for this
some steps have to be taken in order to
reconstruct the solution of the
original formula and for this purpose
we introduced the curator proof system
this
is joint work with marine and army and
here we have rules for clause removal
clause addition
and clause modification
on the one hand so claus removal and
addition
works um with uh
works with curate on existential
literals cause modification with
we get with uh curate on universal
literals on the one hand and the other
hand we need
a generalization for universal reduction
and
this we had to introduce in order
to capture all
proof or pre-processing techniques in
particular
universal expansion uh for this we
needed
this uh universal reduction whole
um and this generalization of it yeah so
i don't have to the time to go into
details but
yeah this is the rules we have in the
proof system
and this leads us then to a tool chain
which allows us not only
to check the correctness of the
operations of the preprocessor
by checking the the curated trace so we
have
checkers for for the accurate traces and
to check if the
produced formula is correct simplified
formula is really
uh obtained by only doing valid
transformation steps
uh and in particular if the formula is
solved
if the solution is correct um we also
um this was also joined where marin and
amin have uh techniques to extract
uh scrolling functions from curated
traces
in case um the the formula is solved
and uh with catalin
i also came up on a solution
that gives us scrolling functions in
case
uh the formula is not solved by the
preprocessor then we could show that we
can extract a partial function or a
incomplete function from the cura trace
which we can
somehow compose with the formula
obtained from the
from with the function obtained from the
from the qbf solver and this
function this composed function uh gives
us on the one-handed
the solution and with that solver we
could again check the correctness
of the result by plugging it in into the
qbf we get a propositional formula
checking check validity and can decide
that the result is okay yeah
with this i come to the end of my talk
um so
in in qbf solving we have a lot of
different solving paradigm
which are nowadays
um investigated and which give a very
dynamic soviet solving landscape
and very prominent approaches are based
on pure resolution and an expansion
they have very well understood uh
proof systems um yeah for for
q resolution uh it's also important
it's both for both for for expansion
based system and q resolution
uh it's very important to notice that
there are also
variants of the proof systems with
different strengths
and uh somehow orthogonal to that we
have the cured proof system
which characterizes
not only the pre-processing techniques
but in joint work with florian and mine
uh um we could show that
uh was a very powerful pure resolution
based proof system and expansion-based
proof system can be uh captured by by
cured proof systems
yeah and with this i would like to
conclude my talk
i would also like to point out that
there is a new book chapter
in the handbook of satisfiability
which i wrote together with wool of
buyer staff nicholas janata
and florian lonsing and in this
chapter we review the current qbf
solving landscape and they're also
pre-processing
an important role and there you also
find details about
the cured proof system which i just
quickly touched
okay thank you very much thank you
martina thanks for the very nice talk
about
this broad landscape of all these
pre-processing techniques for qbf
um i would like to artak
any questions for martina
maybe let's let me first start with a
question
so what other it kind of intrigued me
and i'm kind of in wondering what but
how you see this is why is
pre-processing so much
more important for qbf than for sat and
moxon we've seen it they are important
there too but
for qbf they're even more important wow
i think in qbf the problem is that
the normal form transformation is really
bad
and this is a very difficult topic so
on the one hand the simplest structure
allows
certain techniques and also um allows us
to
have the the powerful implementation
techniques
that come from the start world like
literal watching or
yeah or all the old cnf techniques
almost transferred to qbf on the other
hand this
uh cnf is not ideal for reasoning on
universal quantification
and um here that
the city transformation does a lot of
harm uh it it restricts also
uh the freedom potentially so that the
satan variables are not necessarily
put at the end they can also be put at
different positions
with some restrictions in the quantifier
prefix and this this makes
the reasoning uh more restricted and
um yeah i did my phd on non-cnf qbf
solving and
um yeah this um
and there there were also many follow-up
works investigating this and
uh it's good to have the structuring to
be absorbing but uh it makes
other things things more difficult or
impossible and uh
therefore i think pre-processing is a
good compromise
um to deal with the structure loss and
still have
uh the power of cmf yeah yeah and
it's also probably the reason why i
think force the
the other representations right the
non-non-pc and
formulas pre-processing is less
effective if i recall correctly right
yeah and it has not been investigated to
the same extent
as as for um
cnf we also have to say
yeah so
[Music]
super tick also asks do you know which
of these pre-processing techniques have
been actually lifted to first order
logic
sorry so to first order
uh yeah i mean i mentioned this a bit so
um
yeah these blocked clauses have been
transferred
there and uh
yeah i'm not sure uh subsumption i guess
i also think bound variable elimination
or predicate elimination i think has
also been
studied
uh and also there was a question from
ziad uh regarding
uh whether the the speakers are willing
to share the slides
yeah sure so i'm happy to share my
slides okay very good
sure i i don't know exactly how to do
this
um but um
uh yeah let's let's um otherwise
you can email me and i can anyone wants
the slides then
i can i can forward them yeah
[Music]
any other questions
okay antonia says that they should
appear
on the on the the simon's web page so
that's also um
yeah so please forward them to either to
me or one of the other organizers and
then we take care of it
yeah and also antonina i kind of
mentioned that
now we will start with the uh getter
town
the the tea time
so this is directly uh following uh
this session
any further questions if not then
i would like to thank martina and also
thank all the other
both the other speakers for the
excellent talks and
um to kind of this is this is great
overview of pre-processing techniques
inside microsoft and qbf so thanks
it's a bit weird i know
but um yeah i'm sure that that
there will be a lot of plus when when we
hopefully finally another not too
distant future can have such a session
again
okay thanks a lot and uh hope to see you
also
okay bye-bye thanks bye